at the very first Oscars two awards were
presented for directing one for comedy
and one for drama but the following year
the directing awards were combined to
acknowledge that the genre of a movie
isn't what matters most but rather the
vision and skill of the filmmaker
bringing the story to the big screen the
mark of a cinematic genius is to craft
an experience that not only entertains
us for a few hours but also stays with
us for a lifetime and reminds us why we
fell in love with the movies here are
the nominees for achievement in
directing Martin McDonough the Banshees
of inner sharing Daniel Kwan and Daniel
scheinert everything everywhere all at
once
Steven Spielberg the fablemans
Todd field tar
Reuben usland triangle of sadness
all right and the Oscar goes to
everything everywhere
known collectively as the Daniels Daniel
Quan and Daniel sheinert met while
studying at an Emerson College in Boston
he began their career as music video
directors
[Music]
oh my God thank you sir uh our fellow
nominees you guys are our heroes this is
weird
um uh this we want to dedicate this to
the mommies all the mommies of the world
to our moms
uh specifically my mom and dad Ken and
Becky thank you for not squashing my
creativity when I was making really
disturbing horror films or really
perverted comedy films or dressing in
drag as a kid which is a threat to
nobody uh
and uh
yeah thank you to everybody who works in
our movie
um I know every director agrees with me
when I say a director is nothing without
their incredible cast and crew this is
my family my friends
um if our movie has greatness and genius
is only because they have greatness and
genius flowing through their hearts and
souls and minds and they gave that to us
to our they gave that precious gift to
our film the world is opening up to the
fact that genius does not stem from
individuals like us on stage but rather
genius emerges from the collective we
are all products of our context we are
all descendants of something and someone
and I want you to acknowledge my context
my immigrant parents my father who fell
in love with movies because he needed to
escape the world and thus past that love
of movies onto me my mother who is a
creative Soul who wanted to be a dancer
an actor and singer but could not afford
the luxury of that life path and then
gave it to me my incredible brothers and
sisters who helped me survive the chaos
of childhood my friends from high school
who taught me the that the sorry I'm
just going to keep going um
for CCC you taught me the liberating
freedom of creativity and joy and your
DNA is in this film as well my
incredible sanjio she rearranged my DNA
every day and it's awful and beautiful
every single time
um
if you ever watch this I hope you know
that uh you should never have to live up
to the standard this is not normal this
is kind of crazy I will love you no
matter what
um I
I
think and and
lastly I just want to go back to my
original point there is greatness in
every single person it doesn't matter
who they are they're it's you have a
genius that is waiting to erupt you just
need to find the right people to unlock
that thank you so much to everyone who
has unlocked my genius this means so
much to us thank you to the academy
[Applause]